le patronat à lui est satisfait que le
gouvernement et éviter de pénaliser
l'emploi et la compétitivité des
entreprises à un moment où elles sont
mobilisés pour réaliser le troisième
pacte national pour l'emploi toutefois
le cnpf regrette que les assurés est à
payer un supplément de cotisation allant
que l'on connaisse les mesures prises
par le gouvernement à propos de sécurité
sociale c'était un peu la crainte parmi
les patrons devoir augmenter leurs
propres cotisations
or ce n'est pas le cas vous êtes
entièrement satisfait si vous voulez de
ce côté là oui pour le reste tout reste
à faire
les entreprises il faut bien le savoir
non plus actuellement les moyens de voir
leurs coûts augmenter si l'on veut
qu'elles restent compétitives pour
acquérir l'énergie nécessaire à notre
niveau de vie et pour maintenir l'emploi
pour lequel nous faisons un gros effort
avec le troisième patient l'emploi
l'heure de vérité a sonné maintenant
dépend de sécurité sociale c'est
seulement plus que les revenus et les
salaires des français ne peuvent plus
être financés par l'expansion il n'ya
plus d'expansion du fait de la pop et
projet parmi les causes du déficit lune
qui n'est pas les plus importants de
mais qui dit tout de même c'est eddy
dont le retard des cotisations
patronales qu'est ce que vous en pensez
là vous savez on en parle beaucoup il ya
toiture le fait 7 milliards de retard
dans ses 7 milliards 5 milliards qui
sont imputables à tout ce qui dépend
directement et indirectement de l'état
en commençant par les hôpitaux le
secteur public et dans le reste est
essentiellement des entreprises qui sont
en règlement judiciaire est bon dit
disparaître mais dans l'ensemble sur
cette réforme de la sécurité sociale
vous les chefs d'entreprise venus de
satisfaits je ne dis pas que nous sommes
satisfait je dis que tout est à faire
maintenant pour gérer la sécurité c'est
là où nous sommes satisfaits que nous
pensons que deux ministres à la tête de
la sécurité sociale vont maintenant
réellement voir le problème de face